hello everyone welcome to our webinar
visualizing big money with big data I am
Felipe Hoffa google cloud developer
advocate and i'm roger key product
manager for cloud platforms open ami yes
and today we're going to be visualizing
big money with big data so let's get
started this is life so if anyone has
questions please add them asked youtube
comment we will be answering them and if
you are watching these in the future
well hi there let's get started with
this i have some data that's super
interesting from the elections it's all
of the other nations that have been made
open by the FEC and then opensecrets.org
texas data collected annotated and
leaves it as open date on the website
and they allowed me to share this data
with you so i have it loaded on the
query and I have this table individual
16 with almost 5 million bros and almost
2 gigabytes of data that we would love
to visualize that's include awesome
awesome so with the query it's really
really easy to start writing sequel
queries you don't need to install
anything which you just need to access
the query and you can write simple
queries or complex queries like this
here I'm looking at how much money each
recipient God so simple sequel query 5
million rows we get the results we get
recipients and now if I want to
visualize these facts i will need other
tools there are plenty of tools but one
of my favorites is my dash read ash
exactly and to install it a rush here is
going to show us the best way a super
simple way to get it running on Google
Cloud awesome so read ash is an
open-source visualization and
dashboarding tool bitnami is a partner
of google cloud platform and we're going
to show you how you can launch a bit
nami read ash image into your google
cloud platform account so first let's
talk a little bit about what our setup
and architecture looks like for this
webinar we're going to be using read ash
as i mentioned visual
as the data that we're querying with
bigquery bitnami is a company that
packages open somewhat mostly open
source applications and delivers them
for customers into their configured
cloud in this case we're going to use
Google cloud platform some of the
advantages of using bitnami are that we
keep all of our images up to date and
patched they are cross-platform so you
can take them now locally you're also
able to use them anywhere else other
platforms as you like and the other
important thing to know is that read ash
is free so what's it provisions into
your Google cloud platform account
you'll be able to use that and ssh in as
you like and it'll show up just as a as
a vm so i have to say i really love your
diagram how it shows that we're going to
get elections theta from opensecrets.org
and load it into bigquery we're going to
read thanks to bitnami we're going to
get readers running on computer and it
correct and we are going to get both
connected right Philippe could you tell
us a little bit about bigquery yeah so
because my favorite tool to analyze data
you can analyze terabytes of the 18
seconds you can share data with other
people or you can keep it totally
private with the top security standards
if that's what you want it's really
really easy to get started as we just so
awesome well I'm excited to take a look
at the flexibility of Google cloud
platform oh let's start our free trial
so everyone gets a $300 for free for 60
days if you start your free trial with
Google Cloud and then you can start
trying all of these products platform
for free yeah and I think with bigquery
you're really only charge against the
queries that you use right now oh yeah
yeah yeah so with the query you don't
need to pay for any kind of servers I
word it would be quite as paid for how
much data you store and how much data
each of your queries queries but if you
are doing not doing anything you don't
need to pay hourly or anything there's
no servers to speak of you see as the
query data you awesome really cool so
why don't we kind of get going here and
take a look at how we how we
get started for this webinar so the
first thing you want to do is after
you've created your google platform
account we're going to jump into the bit
nami launchpad for google cloud platform
this is a catalog of all the open source
applications that you have 44 bitnami
we're going to search for read ash we
have it here hit launch and once we hit
launch it's going to take us to the new
virtual machine page and we're going to
go ahead and use this configuration to
just kind of jump in and create you can
toggle the server sizes and go up if you
like for for more compute or hired this
size and I already kind of have one here
spun up so there we go once you hit
create you are able to see the
application here and this is some of the
application information we can go to the
app this is the info de to log in to the
application we're going to do that here
and boom we've got a running read ash
instance we have a run real that's
perfect well let's use it yeah great so
I mean obviously we want to use read ash
in our existing Google cloud platform
account but it's not going to be that
helpful unless it's connected to a big
query data right so how do we connect
the the realest you just want it to be
query great questions so let's jump in
so we're going to get data sources
inside of read ash and go to new data
source and that's going to automatically
populate bigquery as the first item here
so it seems like you can use read us
with multiple data sources great yeah
yeah you're absolutely right so we've
got you know there's my sequel there's
postgres there's graphite there's even
google spreadsheet in here that's really
cool but obviously we need to
authenticate in so let's generate a JSON
key file and this is again our this is
our google cloud platform console and i
actually have the vm running here so you
can see the activity what i'm going to
do is I'm going to jump into permissions
it might be i am or admin for some of
you live at home and we're going to
create a service account let's just do
re dash e generate a private key boom
new phone booth account awesome ok so
here it is and this is the project that
we launched it into and we want the
project ID as well as the json key file
so here we go we're going to take this
and put this in here and we'll just call
it read ash bigquery example x i'm saved
said and now your readers is connected
to bigquery yes and if you share that
with us with me in fact you already
created an account for me excellent i
can use it on my notebook and i can just
start writing queries for example i can
paste a query a growth here in green ash
my project name is FHP query i have my
data set open secrets and the individual
database and this query should bring
data in but i didn't I think we got an
error yeah I got a neighbor because that
data set is not shared publicly I need
to share it explicitly in this case with
your service account key and I can do
that by copying the user name of this
service account let me copy paste this
and bring it to the bigquery side where
I can look at my data set share the data
set and I can choose to share my data
with an individual or group or
organization or google group in this
case with your service account also i
save these changes now it's shared and
the readers that you just launched it
can look at my private data also now if
anyone else wants to query the data I
will make this as a public just to make
sure that anyone else can look at it too
I can share the data set
I cannot all authenticate the users can
you add Save Changes and now you can all
run the same queries awesome well let's
take it i'm really excited it sounds
like we've got a lot of data to dig into
and a lot of queries why don't we take a
look at some of the stuff oh we've got
yep so for example i created this query
now we'll share three dash okay and you
can look at your computer now all the
queries let's take a look so oh I need
to eat it a name let's go give it a name
money now it's saved now reload let's do
this narrow boom perfect see now we are
sharing queries we can do for example I
can add a visualization let me add a new
visualization here where I can get by
candidate by the stupidity the column
and now we're looking at how much money
each candidate work awesome and if i
refresh mm-hmm she'll be able to do you
get my felicitations yeah yeah oh now
we're tearing at art but we want to
share more we want to share dashboards
and for that last night i created a
dashboard in a different instance of
readers let me show you what I got let
me show show you my open secret stash
board now just a disclaimer we're all
developers here we're not political
pundits so there's definitely insights
in the data but we're going to try we're
going to stay objective yes let's
explore data but let's not get very
political yeah okay so let me show you
what I got here my first distillation
that I got here is how many rows we have
per month mhm this is basically taking a
look at my whole data fed the five
million rows mm-hmm we can see that
there was a big jump in rows in June
that it worked in July and then it has
been going up since ha but this shows me
all kind of donations and so then I
created this other job just to look at
the presidential candidates yeah I guess
what I'm selfishly interested in is to
see how much each candidate ray
per month if you want to see the money
that it can do a lot yes okay so here in
the left side I got the real money okay
that everyone that we collected by month
and then this is my one of my favorite
queries we are looking at all of the
candidates and how much money they got
per month added by month we can see the
results awesome if you want to see the
query just to see how I made this happen
you just hit show source once you click
in and it pops up all the sequel that's
awesome yes so this quiz a little more
complicated than the previous one mm-hmm
but it has the same concepts first I'm
looking at the math here the math part
of the date I'm looking at the recipient
and I'm looking at adding up all the
amount but then and doing some adjoin
yeah with my list of candidates probably
you have to in order to make the
previous chart make sense right exactly
so this is where I get their names
instead of the ids and i'm looking only
for candidates running by President
Felipe when you make changes on the
sequel query does it show up on on the
chart in real time or have to let me
show you for example here i'm doing a
clean up of all the candidates that
didn't get enough donations and all the
months that are strugglers but for
example if i get rid of those filters
just commenting and i say and i run my
query again we get completely new
updated this realization awesome and
this chad really shows you why it is
that clean up there's a lot of
candidates in there we want to get rid
of some candidate barack obama even
raise some money look yeah interesting
that's how data works was ok it's always
good to have some clean up filters and
that's why i love using sequel i can
just start digging into this awesome um
let's go back to the dashboard any
questions that you would like answered
well i'm interested to see how much the
candidate raise per month but on both
sides right so you got the democratic
candidate so then you got the Republican
candidates right I have the perfect way
for you okay basically it took the same
data okay and on one side I put
but on the other side report the
Republicans okay and in this way we can
see more clearly how each candidate
progress on the year so if you see here
this is interesting because it looks
like Hilary Clinton really started out
strong in terms of aggregate value of
donations yeah do you see these little
yellow one yeah that's very Sanders
thats that's growing the nation's how up
and to the right look at that happened
to the right yeah and in the last month
march they've I guess the last last bar
kind of Eclipse the other one yes like
20 million versus 19 that's interesting
according to the data have here Bernie
Sanders got more money much than Hillary
Clinton hmm and he started really really
slow hmm so it's pretty cool to see what
about the Republican candidate oh we
have way more candidates here yeah
there's one big standard donation months
june for Jeb Bush I was raised a lot of
money that at that time mmm not the yeah
the rafters are so it was like okay so
there's there's Jeb and then all the way
on the right we have this green bar here
that stands out who's that that is Ted
Cruz ha not in the race anymore but yes
he was really good at racing by renault
yeah that's really interesting really
interesting and it's sorry one last
question where's Donald Trump Donald
Trump he's here he's a has a very small
green bar okay because he had thought
for make sense yeah yes okay interesting
what's this next visualization okay so
here I could up how much money each
candidate collected here we can see that
Hillary Clinton got more money than any
other candidate that shows here it does
make sense with the previous data where
she was raising strong too so I guess
the aggregate here on the left hand side
makes sense exactly what we have here i
have done 40 million for Hillary mm-hmm
versus almost three millions of raise
money for Donald Trump hmm that's a huge
difference he's a pretty big difference
whats this red line Oh with this red
line I was trying to visualize what's
the average donation that each candidate
God huh
so like for example if you had a lot of
really small donations then that number
would be much smaller right exactly so
for example the average donation for
Hillary East 565 dollars yeah kind of in
middle of the pack okay versus Bernie
Sanders week whose address to the nation
is a hundred and forty dollars
interesting who's the where's the spike
what oh this is Jeb Bush duh okay look
pretty big donations when he was getting
the man anxious got it yeah yeah
aggregate average value was higher okay
interesting so next visualization yeah
sure uh industries yeah that makes it I
do kind of want to see how it gets
broken down and and and where they're
coming from it sounds really interesting
yes so open secret does a good job of
looking at the employer of each donor
and then they categorize this by
industry so you can start looking at
what industries are donating more money
to each candidate and we can get a
little bit relation like this mm-hmm I
would love to go deeper into this but
maybe you can leave that for another
winner yeah definitely you know what I'm
really interested to see I would really
like to see the amount of money raised
per candidate that's the first one but
also compared to the number of votes and
I mean this is the primaries right so
the number of Delegates that they got
that's that's the first thing the second
thing that I'm really interested to see
is how much they spent per vote in /
delegate hi so those are super
interesting questions yeah I want so you
want to see of all the money they raise
hell divide that by the number of votes
yes so I wrote that way already okay and
I have my visualizations here and the
left side you can see the ratio of votes
to money and the right side you can see
the ratio of votes of money to delegate
hm what do we mean by this basically for
example Bernie Sanders in Arkansas race
about two thousand dollars more than
almost three thousand dollars
but each boat he got wow that kind of
makes sense I mean you know it is so so
this is kind of reflective of the
strength of the organization's
fundraising and how much resources or
whatever it is that they put into
getting donations / for that say / the
number of votes that they got yes so
smaller meals more efficient yes with
less money they got way more vault yes
you can see that for example Donald
Trump raised very little money yeah and
then he got a lot of votes sure so we
can really see that ratio here yeah but
what we really care about with primary
its delegates delegates no one knows how
that works yeah but they have the 135
yes here are how much money each one
race per day per day later state /
delegate so just to give you a random
fact point Ted Cruz in North Carolina he
raised about thirty thousand dollars
buried away that he finally got wow
that's really interesting yeah we can
start going deeper into this chart
visualizations let's look at let's look
at expenses that's the one I'm Carrie
expensive yellow instead of money
donated is come much money they spent to
get votes and then also to get delegates
okay let's end up with that here is a
very simple visualization we take all
the money that it can be there what
spent spent that's also open data and
then we divided by the number of votes
yes the Carson basically spent fifteen
and a lot of money almost forty-eight
dollars for each voter about Hillary
Clinton is at eleven dollars per vote
Donald Trump twenty-seven cents per pod
at a quarter per vote huh yes Wow
basically that's spending not much money
and getting a lot of notes Wow and then
of course you want to know delegate yes
I guess what really makes a difference i
guess in primaries yes and again we have
something that shows a ben Carson spin
about 4.5 million dollars for its
delicate is there a way to kind of clean
this up so that we can maybe see the
rest of them it looks like this the ben
Carson is kind of skewing the data a
little bit oh yeah let edit is query and
show you the source of miss query
basically the same logic as before yeah
and here I'm going to filter out a band
okay so if i can do it is called band we
are filtering it out okay and let's
visualize that sounds good mm-hmm here
we have it the same shot without the
really interesting really interesting
yes so yeah you know can see the
different of that amazing so how much
did how much did what's the lowest
number on there I almost three thousand
dollars per telling her delegate okay
compared to marco rubio's two hundred
thousand dollars per day yeah i just
find so much fun I know a few data
simple questions that's amazing yeah I I
love playing with this data sharing
visualizations that affect their it's
it's I think one thing to be able to
draw intelligible conclusions about
where you're going to be with you know
slicing and dicing data but showing it
on the screen and visualizing it in a
way that is accessible to a lot of
people is really visible it's really
really fun and everyone could do it a
bit where is open for everyone come on
allies another state everyone has a free
terabyte to analyze every month and with
the free trial you can launch your own
read ash server and and use your bippy
damages in your Google apart from
account yes and launch any other kind of
open source software like yeah like
wordpress drupal and the like so okay so
thank you very much for coming here
today thank you for joining us yes
please stay cool roof and let's see you
in the next video see you in the cloud
thanks